41,000 people have died in England Wales
after testing positive for covin 19 that
is because in the last our the Office
for National Statistics has released its
latest death figures up to the week
ending the 15th of May they reveal that
40 1220 deaths involving coronavirus
were registered well i economics editor
ed Conway has the latest on these
figures ahead
yeah thanks these are really the most
comprehensive numbers that we get on the
number of people who have died and
there's this it's worth emphasizing
covers England and Wales we do have
numbers as well for Scotland and
although I'm telling us a more or less
similar thing although the numbers
aren't as elevated as they are
particularly in England and as you say
over 41,000 according to those official
numbers 41,000 people having died of
code 19 or at least had it on their
death certificate there are also other
numbers we get from the Office for
National Statistics covering not just
covered 19 deaths but deaths from all
causes and in a way those are perhaps a
more representative sense of just what's
going on overall to mortality in this
country because they kind of show you
areas essentially where deaths have
actually exceeded code 19 deaths so for
instance over that period as you
mentioned 41,000 deaths from kovat 19
but if you look at the comparison
between the number of deaths that we've
had that we you normally get any year
and the number of deaths we've had so
far this year it's actually closer just
looking at my numbers to 50,000 over
50,000 I'll give you a sense of that if
you just look at this chart here this
line here shows you in the past five
years how many people have died in given
weeks of the year so starting the start
of the year and going through two - week
20 which in this case is the 15th of May
and here's the line so far this year you
can see a very big increase indeed and
as I say this is deaths from all causes
it's not just coded 19 it is from all
causes but you can see a very big
increase here and then you'll probably
remember last week it looked very much
as if this line was going to head down
and
potentially meet that lines that we've
been back to a kind of average level of
mortality in the UK but instead it's
risen in the last week so we have access
that's actually rising will tell the
kind of actuaries talk about the idea of
excess deaths here and that's the
difference between this black line and
the blue line there now
part of the reason it's worth
emphasizing really is down to the fact
that this is partly about registrations
and in that previous week week 19 that
included VE Day so that bank holiday
that's an extra day that wasn't
available for registrations and
therefore partly this was a bit too low
and this bit here is catching up on some
of those registrations that didn't
happen the previous week so that looks a
bit worse than it really should be but
the overall picture Adam is that that's
not necessarily getting down to what you
might consider normal levels and also
finally if you look just around
different settings so deaths in
different places in England and Wales
you get a similar picture so this line
here the zero line is just the kind of
normal average level in previous years
as I was showing you were talking about
excess deaths here this line shows you
deaths at home so in domestic settings
this line shows you deaths in hospital
so again a very big increase there and
then down to kind of more or less
actually below average levels last week
and then rising up to above average
levels but it's care homes really where
the epicenter of this crisis is if you
have a look at what's covered in your
care homes I don't if I'm to show that
now there we are so care homes you can
see have peaked even higher in terms of
excess deaths so deaths above the
average level even higher than in
hospitals and still right now care home
deaths are above the levels that we see
elsewhere around the country in terms of
deaths at homes after hospitals destined
how the settings indeed so this is
really underlines the fact that it is in
care homes that the mortality crisis
still is in England and Wales and a lot
of focus will be on that in the coming
weeks and it is a reminder really over
all these numbers that we are not back
to normal levels or mortality in this
country which perhaps is something that
policymakers may dwell on when they're
deciding just how to end the lockdown
and whether there is still danger of
indeed continued
mortality and excess deaths around
ignorant of worlds and the rest of the
UK and I just want to ask you briefly
about your road colleague your fellow
economics editor at the Financial Times
Chris Giles he is producing regular
projections for the UK and he's actually
saying that the projections of deaths
relating to Co vyd he thinks and
probably something in you know the mid
60 thousands
well that's pot I mean that's basically
excess deaths so when I talk what we've
got here is excess deaths and yeah
actually those numbers and I mentioned
at the start so you have numbers for
Cobert 19 deaths official coded 19
deaths that is around 40,000 41,000 see
as you were saying in England at least
and so if you include Scotland as well
you're kind of getting up to two closer
to kind of 15,000 just ANCOVA 19 deaths
but then on top of that you have to add
on all of the deaths that are happening
around this time of year that you
wouldn't normally expect and if I just
go back to this chart here you know
about 80% of the gap between those two
lines is explained by covert 19 but that
still leaves an extra kind of it's about
15 to 20 percent that doesn't really
have an explanation and so that's where
the numbers you know that crystals at
the FT and some people are talking about
60,000 deaths rather than 50,000 it's
because you have those excess deaths
above that what we would expect or what
is explained by Kovac 19 and some people
would say no that that's going a little
bit far because some of those deaths
won't necessarily caused by the viruses
other people will say well they're just
undiagnosed and anything when you take a
step back anything above the average
needs to be considered and I think that
to be honest with you is closer I think
these numbers excess deaths from all
causes giving you a real sense of what's
going on and mortality in the UK leaving
aside the questions of whether doctors
have correctly put covert 19 on the
death certificate that gives you a more
kind of comprehensive sense of what's
going on with the number of people sadly
dying in England and Wales and indeed in
the UK and when you look at that you are
talking about numbers over 60,000 so
covert 19 official deaths you're talking
about four
to 50,000 in all of the UK but excess
dad's so from all causes above what you
would normally expect around this time
of the year seasonally then you're
talking about probably sixty sixty five
thousand or so at the moment these are
very high numbers they are far higher
than anyone wanted or expected early on
for this disease so a lot of focus will
continue to be on these numbers in the
coming weeks